foreign
[Music]
special guests all over your sisters and
we wanted to talk a little bit more
about
um the sisters in the ummah and the
dynamic between you know brothers and
sisters in Islam so all right bro take
it away what's the topic alhamdulillah
so today we are going to be discussing
this uh this questions age-old question
that can men and women be friends I
don't know why it's up to debate I don't
know why there's on this it shouldn't be
that much of a difference in opinion we
know these than Islamic people but we
still want to understand where a lot of
these brothers and sisters are coming
from that are purporting this idea that
men and women can indeed be friends some
of them are even supporting it to the
point where they think it's necessary in
life without further do I want to
introduce these alone about it you guys
want to be you know
sure assalamualaikum my name is I go by
that American mahaja
um so with uh the topic it's an
important one you're right I don't
understand uh such a huge difference but
actually when you say that
um some people are saying it's necessary
I am a bit of a realist so I can see why
they say that not entirely sure I agree
with it but we'll leave that for the
rest of the live stream
um let's hear from the other sisters
my name is
and
I'm also in a similar position as a
because
I also even though we all live in the
west and there are obviously instances
where we are forced to interact with the
opposite sex I think it's important that
we still keep our Islamic values and you
know maintain that level of respect when
we talk to each other
very well said okay
I
and
um I think it's a rising topic
especially since we go to Union School
with uh opposite genders
so it's gonna be a nice discussion
Rami bro what about you what are your
thoughts
on can men and women be friends
um
I'm of the opinion that is it's an
absolute No-No both from you know a
secular perspective and especially from
an Islamic one and the reason for that
is because there are very specific
guidelines between men and women you
know interacting in Islam
um there is a huge emphasis on
segregation in a lot of aspects of life
um for example when we uh go to the
Masjid the women always pray behind the
men and there are multiple Hadith that
you know specify that the men should be
in the farthest Rose to the front the
woman should be the farthest Rose at the
back and so on and so forth not the
women should leave
um and that the men shouldn't even
really turn their head all the way so
that they look behind them and see the
sisters or something like that so
there's a lot of Islamic basis on there
being boundaries between men and women
and being a a friend with opposite
gender completely omits and overlooks
all those boundaries I don't know why
there's a box on my face right now to be
honest do you guys see that do you have
the face yeah yeah let me uh let me try
and fix that no worries bro and while he
does that inshallah we will continue
this discussion I agree with almost
everything he said wholeheartedly
um islamically there's there's no
question but you know we we talk about
this concept A Lot on our channel that
there's what there should be islamically
and then there's what's actually going
on in reality because in the west we
live amongst you know not Muslims we
live amongst people of all different
faiths religious cultures and a lot of
us lose our Islamic identity because we
feel compromised to conform to these
social norms so you know it's very hard
to hold on to these values and Society
in a way is kind of pushing this
narrative that we're brainwashed were
barbaric or a little bit too extreme and
it's okay to just chill out you know
free mix Live and Let Live and I think
that's where a lot of these problems
come because many Muslims and Muslims
are not firmly rooted in their religion
so when they come to the West they don't
know any better they go to school they
listen to whatever the teacher is
telling them and before you know it
they're in a Haram relationship right
and that easy I also want to understand
that there's there's there's nuances to
this like anyone that has a case for
this they're not always out here trying
to do something some of them generally
are misinformed or misguided some of
them are living in a fairy tale thinking
that it's possible for men and women to
be platonic that there's no polarity
there's no attraction so there's many
different things we can talk about as
you can see brother Rami I Love About It
Grow the face tracking is gone
um and we can see the note on your face
so why don't you take over and start
with any common argument that you hear
for people saying here is why men and
women can't be friends
just to specify why when men and women
can be friends can be friends yes
um I mean a lot of the the arguments I
hear is oh you know we are more
civilized now and we are able to you
know have men and women who are friends
and talking and hanging out and sharing
their thoughts and beliefs and you know
life stories without any instance of a
feeling from from either or for the
other person that's usually it's usually
from a place of I'd say um and I don't
mean this in a rude way but it's usually
from a place of ignorance that
um you know oh they don't I don't like
them and I know they don't like me
what the heck do you know you don't know
a damn thing I'm sorry especially for
the Sisters out there I know a lot of
the time they you know they probably see
friendships as more platonic but they're
getting a huge you know emotional
connection from this person which even
if they don't see it in an intimate way
uh they do you know love those
connections whereas they don't know what
the heck's going on in the the guy's
head and more often than not maybe
there's like a one percent but 99 of men
who are attracted to women at least
um will like you or wait for some kind
of opportunity and I guess a better way
to say this is 99 of men
um are only friends with women they find
attractive if they are friends with
women they're only women who they find
attractive and uh the women that you
know both they find attractive and are
willing to talk to them
so you thought it comes from a place of
ignorance I would actually argue that it
comes from a place of delusion actually
um and especially on the sisters part
because you're right
um uh you guys might have heard of this
um experiment social experiment that
kind of happened like way back it's been
I think like well over 10 years now
probably I think it was at University of
Utah where they asked um men uh they as
like college students basically on
campus they asked boys and they asked
the girls basically and they asked do
you think that do you think that guys
and girls can be friends uh platonic
friends and basically all the girls they
say Yes
um while all the guys they actually say
no
um but when the girls when you ask the
girls that when you press a little bit
more and you ask them oh if you uh okay
like they ask like oh do you have like a
specific friend of mine and if you gave
him the chance
um to like you know pursue you like
romantically basically do you think he
would be up for it and all of them said
100 yes so that means that like
subconsciously they know it but like
they're literally just suppressing uh
those thoughts basically and saying oh
no we're just friends we're just friends
we're just friends he's like my brother
but in reality they in in the back of
their minds they do know but again it's
just delusional thinking basically that
uh they're just platonic
um that was very well said what do you
two sisters think about that
going back to um brother Romney's Point
while Society is kind of changing I
think our biology Remains the Same
because the Synergy between masculine
and feminine energies are so it's so
profound that attraction is just
inevitable so it's kind of difficult to
say that all
these male and female relationships will
remain platonic when in reality it's not
100 I agree
I don't know I just feel like
we're human
human so like I don't see it that way
like when I talk to someone I don't
think
um she's a girl she's a guy I just think
they're a human
and like I
feel like
we can't like have acquaintances like a
new knee and work but
um it becomes a problem when we like
when friendships become close basically
okay so you're of the Viewpoint just so
I can clarify this sister that yes we
can but there's like a line to draw yeah
obviously yeah whereas I'm coming from a
point of view where it's like prevention
is the best cure you know what I mean so
why don't you go into that let's let's
pick your brain a little bit tell us
what like what makes you think that you
know when you look at an individual you
don't see them as men as a man or a
woman you see them as just a human being
which is fine by the way you're totally
about to feel that but go into that like
what goes through your mind where do you
draw the line how do you know when to
draw the line
um how do you gauge someone's interest
go into that
uh well usually when I look like when I
talk to someone I give them as a human
even if they're doing bad things they're
doing good things because like I just
feel like someone no matter what someone
does or has is at the end at their core
they're human
um and like I feel like you draw the
line at
close friendship so when you feel like
you're getting too close to a certain
person which inevitably will happen but
then like you either get married or like
you cut a person not cut the person off
but kind of distance yourself from the
person
and how do you personally know when to
draw the line because I'm sure you've
heard of like the slippery slope fallacy
the deeper you go into neat relationship
that it basically normalizes a new
established Dynamic and therefore it
becomes much harder to like have an
objective Viewpoint in how deep you're
getting with someone
yeah that is kind of hard
to know what to draw the line but you
know like you know and to want to draw
the line
okay like you should know
you should know okay Rami what about you
um I just I want to go back to something
you said earlier
um since you asked me you had mentioned
that when you see you know a person you
don't think oh this is a boy or this is
a man or this is a woman you just see
them as a person
um but how do you know that the other
person's looking at you in the same
exact way
you don't but you're not responsible for
the way other people do you responsible
for the way you'll see other people and
you see yourself yeah 100 I I agree you
know we're not going to be held
accountable one for how we feel and two
for how other people view us or you know
feel about us unless we do something
that you know would Inspire them to feel
a certain way that's different but um we
are responsible however for parting
ourselves or not putting ourselves in
certain situations and I think it's very
obvious that when you put yourself in a
situation where inevitably you have to
cut somebody off or you put yourself in
a situation where
um you know you're sitting and talking
to a person with the intention of not
getting close to them
um it's very problematic because it
brings in the question why are you even
really speaking with this person you
know if you're going to develop a
friendship why not do it with someone
who you know you can speak to for a long
time why put yourself in a situation
where it's like oh now I'm married I
have to cut this person off wouldn't it
be better if that was a woman who you
could remain friends with
no but I mean like what if
you're from uni and it's like
I think this is I think this brings up a
good point we should Define friend what
do you mean when you say friend I mean
you meet someone like someone like you
see every now and then
like you go out of your way to see them
or you see them at school in class as
necessary that's cool
okay okay
like once a year or like every six
months wait wait so just I think you cut
off a little bit so are you are you
adding on that you might go out to see
them once a year every six months as a
group obviously like a group of friends
okay all right so are you aware that a
lot of the time
um relationships or not maybe not a lot
of the time but a good amount of the
time relationships don't form
um and I mean intimate ones don't form
basically upon two people meeting a lot
of the time there is intimacy built up
you know between friends and that is
what escalates between you know a man
and a woman not necessarily I just laid
my eyes on you especially for women but
more so something that develops over
time so are you not opening yourself up
to a lot of potential risk for this
person to you know inevitably like you
or for you to inevitably like them
all right yeah I understand the Earth
but I also
you're kind of cutting yourself into the
population
like imagine all the conversations and
all that like the topics and like just
everything like you're cutting yourself
off from half of the population like
that's crazy to me yeah well I mean if
half the population or a good percentage
of half the population views you in a
very explicit Manner and would take any
opportunity to do whatever they want
with you I would say thank God that
you're cutting off those ties and and
those you know possibilities
yeah but do you think
nice sorry can you repeat that sometimes
it cuts off sorry do you think every
person
ever I think 99 of men that would be
friends with you 100 see you in that way
and there were studies done on this or
at least you know YouTube videos made
there were studies done in there were
public interviews
a lot of them a lot of them are awesome
and they asked them do you have any male
friends and then they're just and
they're like and when they called them
they basically you know for the
non-muslims at least not to be too
explicit they just said ask him like you
know we want to hook up or whatever and
when they told him that he said all
right I'm coming over like and they were
shocked the women were shocked because
they were generally under the guise that
it's just platonic but the sheer like
Expressions that they had just to show
that this was not what they expected
goes to show volumes that a lot of the
time women fall for this trap by
feminism that were the same there's
equality so most women like it's a
common law that like majority of women
do not find majority of men attractive
but majority of men do find majority of
women attractive so because of that when
a lot of women go around not basically
having any feelings for their guy
friends they make this mistake that
thinking men are going to be the same so
if I don't find them attractive he
obviously doesn't find me attractive
when there are a lot of Schmucks let's
say that would be willing to be friends
with a woman for like 20 years 10 years
five years just to be in a potential
position to get with her even if he
doesn't make a known right off the rib
yeah and I think to really solidify this
point I want to ask you a question
sister if for every single guy you met
you you know could see a sign above his
head
and it would let you know you know if he
would take any opportunity to do
whatever you know with you would that
affect how many guys you talked to
and it would it affect your outlook on
the situation in men if you saw that 99
of the people you saw had that sign
above their head
oh yes I know
oh yes obviously because he goes out oh
no because I think it's like it's nature
and it's hormonal it's not their fault
um and like
like
you take out of the Friendship what you
want
and under your terms
and obviously when you see like the
limits like like when you see that line
that you need to like where you need to
cut the person off you don't want to do
it okay so I have a question for you
um
genuine question
it goes without saying that
we clearly understand that there's
limits that we should not transgress
over and that we do have Primal I guess
desires that we can't control like our
sister ondo was talking about like the
whole Synergy between masculine and
feminine polarity there's there's no
doubt that this will arise and instill
attraction subconsciously and like a uh
sub-human level even I want to call it
let's say but my question to you is now
do you do you understand that we have
this mentality Sometimes When We are
under Temptation that it's very
difficult for us to do the right thing
or draw the line like you're saying
yeah
so do you understand that being in that
position might Cloud your judgment a
little bit
yeah okay so if you understand that do
you think it's that safer to allow every
human basically have a mentality that we
will know when to draw the line or do
you think that prevention might
um yeah I agree like I agree with you I
just like if you draw the line early
like before that even happens before
that even like like even before that
thought even comes then you're good like
if you draw the line like a uni or like
uh
like you don't talk after school or
whatever
then like
you're like that thought doesn't even
come that situation doesn't need to come
it doesn't
appear yeah yeah and and Romney do you
have anything to say and then I have
some questions with all the Two Sisters
yeah I just I just wanted to ask I think
this question came up earlier but you
know who not only where do you know when
to draw the line but who who has the
right to draw the line you know wouldn't
our creator who created us and knows us
inside out everything about us wouldn't
they know best what the you know best
practices for us are if we should
segregate when and how we should
segregate
um whether we should limit conversation
with the opposite gender as much as
possible or whether there is an
allowance for that
yeah
yeah and do you believe that in Islam
there are not very clear guidelines for
you know when we are allowed to speak to
office opposite gender like for example
if there's necessity or if you are
working with you know uh members of the
opposite gender at work and they
originally need something for work or
vice versa
no I think it's very clear to be
okay and do you think that this idea
that well I can talk to them since we're
in school or I can go out once a year or
every six months with them in a group
um even though more conversations are
going to be taking place in public do
you not think that those violate the
Islamic guidelines
uh
well there's no there's no clear like no
but sorry there's no there's no clear
what you cut off but there's no clear
yes or no to that question
but in my opinion like if it isn't clear
then it's a no
okay that's I think that's very fair if
there's a gray area then you should be
safe rather than sorry yeah basically so
I would say no
okay I think that's very fair Jose
okay so my question to the other two
sisters is have you all ever had I don't
want to say a phase but just parts of
your life where you had a differing
Viewpoint than you do now perhaps a
little bit more indoctrinated by Western
programming or what they teach you in
the education system or what you see in
society did you guys always have the
view that you have right now
not exactly
I think everybody at this stage like I
think because of just like the global
culture and everything right and just
growing up in the west like where just
the feminist ideology is the absolute
Norm it's impossible for a Muslim living
in that situation to not be affected at
some level
um so to some degree you do end up
leaving basically everything that is
repeated like about oh guys and girls
can be friends you have to go to school
you have to talk obviously you have to
be normal you can't just sit in a corner
and just like you know uh be quiet and
cut off from everybody and then
obviously all of your other all of your
even if you have just like female
friends all your females and they're
talking to guy friends and they're going
out in group settings uh ancestry
Yasmine also mentioned
um so if all of the all of the outings
basically are group outings then you
don't want to be left out and there's
also like you know there's peer pressure
there's all these things basically that
play a role so it's very very rare I
think to find uh people that are have
always just been immune to that and I
think uh probably
um can kind of tell us a little bit more
about her experience because she was
mentioning something
yes well when I was in school about when
I was about 14 or something
because this feminism ideology was quite
prominent you know it's their way of
like it's kind of basically like
propaganda and unfortunately because I
was so
surrounded by these like values and
Norms I was indoctrinated as well and I
was you know manipulated to believe that
men and women aren't the same we think
the same
a girl can do what a boy can do and that
we're psychologically on the same level
but
after I reconnected with Islam about in
lockdown I realized of course that you
know this is the reality this is the
real world it's a very idealist way of
thinking that everyone can be happy
there are no differences that men and
women can
do anything yeah
yeah so what happened when you you know
abandoned these previous beliefs where
was like the turning point
I think the turning point was
it was I don't know I don't know if
there was a turning point to be honest
because it was kind of like gradual
because these feminist kind of views
were so woven into me subconsciously
that even when I reconnected with the
sun I still some Islamic rulings but
kind of triggered me inside so it took a
long time for me to get rid of these
views and I think
foreign perspective
so for me actually there was a pretty
clear Turning Point
um with this so what happened with me um
I kind of moved around a lot
um and there's a thing I Believe by
correct me if I'm wrong but I believe it
was Hazard um
who said
um that to be alone is better than to
have bad company but to have good
companies better than being alone so for
me basically
um once when we moved
um I was basically distant from my old
friends which was not I don't want to
call them Bad Company because they
weren't really bad but they were just
like you know it was this like being
friends with guys and all this stuff
basically and going out and like you
know mixed mixed Gatherings and all this
stuff basically
um so then when I was cut off with that
that's when I think it's fun a lot like
Allah guided me to a lot of things and
it also made me realize that like just
kind of getting comfortable with being
alone is I think super important because
um there's uh something else another
question that I think someone wanted to
have answered about like you know
um what about like Tom tomboy girls
basically like you know people that
don't get along with other girls but
again it's better that you're alone than
that you fall into potential sin
basically it's better to and it's better
to be patient while being alone than to
follow into eventual sin basically
because to some degree like you know you
can't all all most acquaintances as well
I know we try to give gray area to the
acquaintances because oh it's not like
you know super close friendships like
for example people justify people
justify going on dates nowadays because
oh it's in a public space so that Hadith
about like you know how uh when a man
and women are alone
um the third is shaytan they say oh see
I'm not alone with her it's a public
space so apparently it's okay to go on
dates now but that's not how it works
you can't just talk to her and flirt
with her openly just because uh there's
like 10 other people also on dates
basically right
so there's all this stuff as well so
getting comfortable with being alone I
think is also super important and then
just like making an effort to find good
company and not like you know
sacrificing
um not sacrificing what you believe
basically just to fit in just to please
other people and Allah really rewards
that that's one thing that I've really
experienced in my life when you make
sacrifices for Allah he will reward that
to the max like I have been blessed with
the best company and every time people
try to like you know this fear-mongering
habit of oh if you don't if you don't
talk to the opposite gender how are you
going to find a spouse well
alhamdulillah I found the best spouse
and I didn't have to talk to anybody uh
so it's just you know it's the same just
this idea of like you know sacrifice for
Allah's sake and trust me he will reward
you
alhamdulillah may Allah bless you and
your marriage
and it's crazy how much I can relate to
that I've heard so many countless
arguments from the other side that oh if
it's in a group Gathering it's fine or
it's in a public setting or anything
like that as if that changes anything
um so I want to give a shout out to
Victor for the stupid chat men and women
can never be friends I started being a
friend to a girl and we ended up engaged
and I will bless you bro
um creative Rami us all right your best
friend should always be your husband and
wives insha Allah
young Welsh writes I thought this was a
Pentecostal Christian discussion
what Christian denomination is this I
don't know how you got here bro but
this this ain't going over here so I'm
gonna pull up some some questions that
we got in the DMS uh you want to take
over inshallah in the meantime
sure inshallah uh on a quick note of
that guy who asked what Christian
denomination this is he did that I think
a few streams ago so it's just his
his little joke I guess he comes in our
chat and asks which Christian
denomination we are what kind of like
sermon I think is just something he does
for fun Welsh bro is this is the part
where we're supposed to laugh
let's see okay so the first question is
um I'm going to keep it anonymous
but the the sisters you know who it is
uh do you have any advice for sisters
that only have guy friends so growing up
I don't have necessarily favorable
experiences with female friendships
throughout primary school I was deemed
as weird therefore let's just say
amongst the girls for whatever reason I
just mainly had guy friends and we just
clicked more
um most of the stuff that I found
interesting they find it interesting too
it makes me happy because I finally had
friends that I can relate to they don't
ostracize me or judge me for anything
they just like hang around with me
perhaps this is the starting point of me
growing up a tomboy
um so thoughts on that
any of you Bismillah take it away
I personally think that even if this
relationship does make you happy I think
that pleasing Allah is more important
because of course islamically it would
be impermissible
um okay
I think it's a common thing that happens
though because okay girls at a certain
age especially like that middle school
high school age are really catty
honestly I had a tough time finding
friends too but again it just goes back
to kind of what I was mentioning before
you have to get comfortable sometimes
with uh an uncomfortable situation
um and giving preference to basically
what is islamically correct and trust
that Allah will reward you for that
because
um uh that's after after a certain age
girls are pretty nice honestly and then
also maybe you've just had some bad
experiences not everyone is like that
there's also plenty of good people as
well
um just because you have some bad
experiences doesn't mean you should stop
trying
um maybe try a different set of friends
basically a different Circle
um but definitely being uh comfortable
with being
um just by yourself and not necessarily
even if you don't necessarily fit in
it's okay because again
um he said that the dean is something
that is strange and it will revert to
being something that is strange so the
Believers the Muslims they shouldn't
they they can't always uh desire this
feeling of fitting in you can't have
this idea because the Muslim was not
made to be uh to be like you know just
like anyone else we are meant to stand
out we are meant to be different
um we have a standard that was dictated
by a law and resources and that's what
we follow and that's what we give
preference to so even if you feel
comfortable talking to the guys even if
these are the nice they could honestly
be the nicest guys on the planet maybe
they're actually maybe they have no bad
intentions maybe they really help you
out and everything but still you have to
make sure they're not more than
acquaintances you cannot be counting uh
crossing any boundaries
um because there's there's no benefit in
um in earning the displeasure of Allah
really
um so it says there's there's a
difference between acquaintances or like
forced interactions like okay I have to
be paired up with this person for like a
group project or like you know he's my
partner in a lab that type of stuff
versus you going out of your way to like
do do the most you know what I mean and
usually people know what they're doing
and it's it's a very good reminder for
and so Yasmine what do you think about
that
uh I think you can't tell the kid
who to be friends with and who to not be
friends with like
until like there are at a certain age I
think it's fine to be honest because
like then they go
to be okay with the other gender and
we've seen this a lot because like for
example in Saudi before before they
opened up and everything like people
would travel and like like
they'd be shocked to have a culture
shock because they didn't know what
women were like a man didn't know what
women were
and like I think it's healthy actually
for kids to
mingle like with the opposite gender so
do you do you believe that if kids can
be exposed to the other gender from a
very young age that it's gonna be easy
for them so I guess not intermingle or
free mix once they hit that age where
they are going to be having to draw
these lines
no I I just think
no I don't think it's obviously gonna be
a harder but I think there should be a
lines drawn even as kids
but like less harsh lines I guess
um that's interesting Rami what do you
think
well it's not firstly on the last topic
I wanted to add that the ends does not
justify the means in Islam you know a
common example is if you want to give in
charity to by the way people donate to
um to Syria and turkey donates our
brothers and sisters they need it
um but if someone wanted to give in
charity it's not permissible to rob a
bank and then donate everything to
charity
um actually as a matter of fact if you
get money in any Haram way you sh are
basically told as far as I know you know
go to a scholar to correct me uh if case
I'm wrong just to confirm but as far as
I know you're you're supposed to donate
that money without expecting any reward
from Allah so even if you do reward you
know do donate it
um you're not rewarded because the again
the ends never justifies the means so if
your goal is to have a meaningful
conversations
um
does not give you permission to go talk
to the opposite gender and put yourself
in you know a bad scenario or engage in
any kind of Haram for the sake of a
conversation I don't think that kind of
reasoning would line up and imagine you
know you're married
and your husband or wife is talking to
the opposite gender and you ask why do
you need to talk to this person you're
like you don't give me good
conversations and nobody else does so I
need to talk to this guy you know is
that something is is justifiable I don't
think even women nowadays would accept
something like that I think they would
be very upset
um but what was there's something I want
to say on the specific topic just remind
me what the question was
okay so the question was basically the
sister reaching out to us
um for lack of a better word and she was
basically asking that you know growing
up she never had favorable favorable
experiences to the same sex so to other
sisters and the interactions were weird
maybe they were judgy maybe they didn't
align with their views or opinions but
she clicked more with the men and she
was like I feel the community that
belongingness that love that alignment
the Brotherhood with the guys and
because of that she's asking like you
know I can't have that with women I
finally have guys what do you think
about that you know you know what I
genuinely think and I'm not saying this
about this sister in particular right so
if you if you're watching sister who
asked that do not think I'm thinking and
talking about you specifically but it is
something that I think you should
reflect on what is this amazing
connection that you're getting from
these men
is it something that you're not getting
from women because
um you know you don't have women around
you that can you know provide you with
that but the women exist or is it
because they're men that you feel a
connection to them that you should be
feeling from you know
um other men who should be giving you
attention you know such as your husband
or your father or your brothers these
are supposed to be the masculine men in
your life taking care of you making you
feel provided for and comfortable
um not random men in the street
um so I think maybe you should really
reflect on that are these men that I
feel close to because they're giving me
attention and I don't want to say
validation because I feel like that's a
little rude to use in this context but
you know they're giving you this
attention and this emotional connection
as a man and that's why you never
resonated well with women because there
are definitely women out there who have
the same interests as you whether it's
you know Islam and Sharia or Akida or
it's you know knitting or arts and
crafts or whatever it is they exist you
just have to find them
I don't know about it bro that was well
put together the question that we got
from someone else asking uh what are
your thoughts on having uh a friend who
is not straight I don't want to say and
get this video demonetized but
um it reminds me of a Hadith
on one day I ended up on and there was a
man that was in the house it was one of
those you know back then they had these
these like asexual you know housekeepers
where people lived in the house either
they had like node at least or they were
basically like they weren't functional
in that way they were just asexual or
whatever and because they had that
predisposition a lot of them stayed in
the house and that the prophet saw him
walked in on the mat
describing this woman that he basically
had found on the street and describing
how she walked and how she moved and
keep in mind that there was no threat
like the this man knew who actually was
married to he knew the prophet saws
there was no lines being crossed but
with quickness he literally no
hesitation he said this is like the last
time you're gonna be here because I fear
that the way that you were describing
other women you were going to describing
my work like that so it just goes to
show that yes perhaps there's no
interest with him and her but he's still
a man at the end of the day who was
deemed to not be a threat but clearly
and I'll put up the Hadith something
from
yeah and also that I believe that person
was a eunuch you know I beat people are
people that don't have the facilities
anymore because they were you know
um those facilities were omitted from
their bodies to say the least so there
is no possibility of anything but a guy
who you know has an attraction to or
claims to have an attraction to the
opposite gender
um that does not necessarily mean oh no
you could talk to them because one maybe
you will feel a certain way about them
and two maybe they don't only have an
attraction to opposite gender and three
I mean you never know he still has the
ability you know that is still dangerous
um and that does not give the excuse or
omit the ruling that with the opposite
gender we should have very strict
boundaries
I wanted to add something that when I
was in university bro there was this
person that in in one of our classes
there was this girl and then there was a
guy right so the guy was not straight
the girl was straight she found him
attractive she knew there was no chance
of them getting together because he was
not straight yet she still tried to get
him to change his mind for four years
like that is
absurda like despite her knowing that
this orientation she still wanted that
so a lot of people just come to terms
with accepting it on a logical level
even if they do in a subconscious level
we don't know how we operate we don't
know how
we're not aware of these thoughts that
we have but what do you sisters have to
say about that
that's definitely true and that's not
the only case actually where you
mentioned that
um about like uh having a homosexual
friend basically
um uh but then there's so many cases of
that there's literally
um so many um I think if you I think I
watched like a YouTube video about this
where
um people thought that like you know the
case scenario was that the girl was
straight but the guy was also like you
know he wasn't straight and they still
end up falling into Zuna basically and
she gets pregnant by him basically so
these situations occur way common
actually it's a and then considering
also now where the West has this concept
of um like you know sexuality exists on
a spectrum right nowadays nobody's just
gay nobody is just lesbian basically
everybody is just some level of bisexual
some level of something basically they
don't like that they don't like to be
called just gay anymore so there's no um
even if you think that they're
somebody's homosexual and then the other
thing is if some if you're friends with
somebody that can be homosexual first of
all I don't I don't know how you could
be friends with someone like that
because how can you um if someone is
disregarding Allah's will uh and I and
by the way I mean not someone who has
those feelings but someone who's
actively acting on it definitely because
again we're not held responsible for our
feelings but if somebody's literally
acting on an openly openly talking about
for example their feelings of being a
homosexual person
how can you uh be a friend and validate
those feelings basically and how will
you answer to Allah basically about that
like uh there has to be a certain level
of dissociation I think from sin and
from sinful
um environments sinful people as well to
be honest
um
oh sorry go on okay thank you and I was
going to say that I agree with that
because if we maintain these boundaries
between men and women we can avoid
unnecessary conflicts because especially
when you know rules are made based on
General trends no exceptions
um yep that's facts someone commented
you can only be friends if you don't
find her most attractive I disagree with
that because when two people are in a
relationship and this relationship
doesn't have to be by the way an
intimate relationship it could just be a
friendship even that is a relationship
that no two people even if they find
both each one another unattractive the
degrees and extent to which they find
each other unattractive are not ever
going to be the same rarely meaning one
person is always going to find the other
person slightly more unattractive and
the other person is going to find the
other person slightly less unattractive
so whoever finds the other person
relatively a little bit more attractive
without trying to confuse y'all they
will have a subconscious pursuing or or
longing for that person more than the
other one if if that makes sense a lot
of times you see this with men and women
that sure the man finds are unattractive
the woman finds unattractive but the
woman completely like sees him as like
let's say a minus 10 but then the man
sees her as let's say like a minus two
so relatively he still likes her more
than she likes him and because of that
it will reflect in his behaviors a time
where she's vulnerable or sensitive or
complaining to her about a man or
whatever and Men usually always take
this opportunity to get what they want
and sometimes women get blindsided by
that because they have this idealistic
world view that there's nothing that can
happen between us
mm-hmm
also
um I don't believe that I don't believe
that no attraction can exist between
friends because the reason you're
friends with someone is because you are
attracted to something about them you
wouldn't be friends with someone you're
not attracted to at all whether that's a
physical aspect of them or like
something about their personality or
something and we know that personality
also beautifies uh a person's looks
basically over time as well so you're
going to end up attracted to her if
initially even if you think that she's
the ugliest girl on the planet
um first of all I don't think guys would
be friends with the ugliest girl on the
planet but even if you were friends with
her just because like you know
personality or whatever that would
eventually translate into other things
like there's no way it wouldn't you are
attracted to her that's why you're
friends with her that is facts I didn't
even think about the see personality
makes
up for a lot of physical I guess
insufficiencies in the way that you view
the other person and there was a show
called Catfish I don't know if any of
you all know it but it's basically where
two people are talking to one another in
like this online relationship they've
never met one another and usually the
person on the other end is is catfishing
them meaning they're not who they
purport to be based on pictures or
whatever sometimes it's completely
different it's a guy it's not even a
girl so there's this one case where this
guy was talking to a girl long term for
a few years I don't know why people do
this without just meeting up and
verifying anything and then it's like
you know cafers they're not Muslims and
then eventually you know he fell in love
with her and the personality and
everything even though he didn't see
what she looked like on some picks
and then when they met up it ended up
being a guy
and not only that he ended up still
getting with the guy because of that
emotional connection so not only is it
what you're saying that they'll change
their perceived attractiveness to the
opposite gender they might even change
their orientation completely
so
rummy bro what's on your mind you can
awfully quiet yeah no I think that's um
I think these are all great the last
point I want to add is imagine we
actually accepted that you know what men
and women cannot be friends except if
you know the guy is gay or the girl is
gay
how many especially men people would
pretend to be just to be able to sit and
talk to a girl and then later come out
as bi or whatever you know after
establishing this huge emotional
connection it just opens up the door to
so much fitna and you know a
vulnerability for our sisters and we
don't want our sisters to be in a
vulnerable position and we want to keep
them protected from a lot of vile men
that are out there
hmm
and people even joke about this stuff by
the way you know like oh when I pretend
to be uh sus so I can get the girl
sleepover and that like people make
jokes about this it's not funny it's
stuck with a lot of nothing so I have a
question for you all three sisters um
and maybe even brother Rami if you want
to answer this but as women growing up
here in the west or wherever you guys
grew up
what from your current understanding of
Islam and where you are in in your Deen
what advice would you have to sisters
and brothers that are in environments
such as being in students or in a
workplace where they have no control
over being forced to interact with the
opposite sex and what I guess lines
would you have them draw and personal
boundaries would you have them exercise
I think when talking to them at school
for instance keep conversations
respectful and only talk about things
that are unnecessary so don't cross the
boundaries of course and talk about
things that are informal just act
professional I would say
um okay
very good
um what about you two sisters
I'd like to hear what yasmina has to say
about this actually because again we're
talking
I really want to know
um kind of how you draw those lines like
where do you think the lines should be
drawn
I'm not quite sure how to answer that
but
I think the line should be drawn like
when either side feels
like it's becoming more than than an
acquaintance
basically
you think life should be gone after yeah
exactly see I think like the beauty of
Islam is that Islam cuts it off before
it gets to that point right where like
for example like in the Quran Allah says
do not even go near Sina he says
um so it's not about when you're uh when
you're almost committing you know
basically and then you think that oh
I've crossed a line I should probably
dial it back it's don't even go like
everything that leads to it is basically
Haram so
um going back to like advice to people
because I did grow up over there and I
went to UNI and all this stuff because
you have to this is and there are going
to be interactions with the opposite
gender whether you like it or not
honestly and it's really hard it is
really hard to be like you know I know
africando said to be professional and
that is the best advice I think
um but what I would say is just make
sure like for example don't uh some
practical things don't give anyone your
number basically don't let It Go Don't
establish any long-term uh long-term
contact with the opposite gender
basically whatever happens in class
stays in class trying to avoid them
outside of class definitely if you're in
a working environment
um you just have to keep it professional
um and again just be comfortable with uh
being different I think that's the most
important advice I would give to all
Muslims to be honest practicing the
religion anywhere because you are going
to feel a little bit like a stranger but
that's not a bad thing that's a good
thing
um so just having that uh having that
kind of mindset I think would help a lot
and what advice sis would you have for
um men and women that are realizing you
know what I've had a lot of friends of
the opposite gender now I realize that I
shouldn't for whatever reason for the
sake of Allah and now I'm going to make
these changes but now I'm going to feel
lonely
well I'm gonna tell you that Allah is
definitely gonna send you better I can
almost I can literally promise it you
can write it in Gold literally as our
parents like to say
um it's 100 fact because when you give
up something for Allah there's I believe
um as well and that's where uh I believe
it was uh on the cinema right the wife
of the prophets
passed away she was distraught she was
like what am I gonna do now how and like
I believe was it resources who advised
her with that Dua basically and she was
like how could how could anyone be
better than Abu Salama because she was
so in love with him he was the best
husband ever but like you know that
there are um it was about like you know
give me better basically and when you
ask that of Allah Allah will give you
better beyond anything you could have
possibly imagined like that is a fact
I've seen it in my life literally so
many times so as Muslims like this
concept of sacrificing for the sake of
Allah is such a such an important part
of the dean and when you do that trust
me trust me trust me Allah will bless
you Allah will give you better so even
if and one other thing a lot of times
people uh don't aren't able to draw the
lines because they're worried about
hurting people's hearts right and
hurting hurting people's feelings
um look ultimately the heart of that
person that you're worried about that
heart is in the hands of Allah so if
you're putting the pleasure of Allah and
you're earning the pleasure of Allah who
controls that heart that you just heard
Allah controls that heart so he has the
power to turn that heart and to take
care of that heart for you as well so if
you have a girl that you're talking to
right now she might be your girlfriend
she might or maybe you're a girl and
you're talking to a guy he might be your
boyfriend
um give it up for Allah's sake and trust
that Allah will take care of that person
for you and if it's meant for you trust
me it's gonna come back to you and it's
Gonna Come back to you in a Halal way
that's actually beneficial for you it'll
be beneficial for you in the long term
it'll be not toxic because current on
Haram relationships are nothing but
toxicity honestly it's not it's not
going to end well even if you end up
getting married how many times do you
hear about people who were literally in
a relationship for years and years and
years but after marriage it breaks apart
because which is crazy versus like you
know you hear about people who did
things the right way for example my
husband I literally talked to him like
twice uh one time in person one time on
a like a FaceTime and alhamdulillah we
got married after discussing obviously
important things
um but when you again keep in mind just
discuss the way that you have to discuss
and you keep Allah's pleasure in mind
you are going to receive Baraka from him
that you could have never imagined was
realistic so don't try to be realistic
trust Allah and he will give it to you
alhamdulillah I think that you couldn't
have you couldn't have done that that
was as good as you could have said a
woman about it because so many times we
we understand that if we let go of
something for the sake of Allah Allah
Allah will give us something better and
and we know this we know this
intrinsically we know this to Islam it's
guaranteed but how many of us can
actually like practice this how many
people can actually implement this and
walk the walk it's easy to say but
sometimes we don't because we we think
that we know better than Allah and we
think that okay we understand where to
draw the line or where to do this where
to do that we have good intention maybe
we're doing bad action
um but most of the cases you write in
these Harlem relationships one party or
both parties usually is one party they
don't have the intention of marriage
they're just dragging it along nobody
wants to make a Halal
um
I love him I mean
all right so I think we're probably
getting close to the end of the stream
it's been about an hour
um one question I do want to ask while
you sisters are here is what are some of
the sisters topics or sisters issues
that you feel are not being represented
enough in the dawa sphere
I have another question about this topic
yeah go for it how about cousins
cousins Fallen under the same category
because you're permitted to get married
to them I believe
so they can they're considered
non-mahara
listen Romy if I have a wife and the
only way she's going to be friends with
a guy is if it's her twin brother
that's it
that's funny I'm serious what if it's a
brother but not a twin
hell no
but definitely what do you what are you
two sisters have to say about any issues
women's issues like brother Rami was
asking
[Music]
um
I think maybe hijab
and uh women's Journeys with her job
because
of course what I think most women are
aware that what is permissible what is
not permissible is just how to approach
it especially in the west because women
are sexualized quite a lot and it's kind
of hard to dress modestly sometimes
okay okay
I think maybe even
um with regards to marriage like
honestly I think I'd like to hear more
about that like what to
um look for in a spouse because as I
think uh I think 80 of people 80 of
Muslims are obsessed with right now just
like you know uh the age group that's on
social media and all this we're always
uh obsessed with the idea of marriage
but um just talking about what are some
like you know uh green flags basically
what are some red flags um in women and
men basically uh you could be providing
um the red flags in men obviously
because you guys know men better because
you are men
um things like that I think would be
nice to see as well
hmm okay I think that's a good point
inshallah
how about you sister uh yes mean
I think addressing the double standards
like with one another Norman so like a
lot of cultures and families like guys
are allowed to do this but girls aren't
we're like islamically
both aren't allowed to
can you give some examples of this so we
have a better idea
uh I'd say my mom tells me to get back
home at 10th because my little brother
he can be home at 1am
like
if like let's say another company like
if a mom finds out that her son is
drinking a lot of yeah but if her
daughter is thinking it's a huge deal
it's about a drinking like alcohol
that is wild do you think do you think
this is this is baseless though because
like what if the the mother is in the
scenario it's your mother or whoever's
mother you understand that let's say a
man can travel with a methadone but a
woman can't travel without him so
because it sounded late at night she's
just having a little bit more potato
more effective jealousy over uh her
daughter
yeah I guess I do understand that
but like
traveling isn't being out it's kind of
different
traveling I mean like just going outside
but it's traveling going outside or it's
traveling like actually traveling what
do you think
um I think there is a bit of a
difference
um going outside
um you know per se it's not like hot on
for a woman or bad for a woman but when
it comes to traveling you know there are
rules around that and there are rules
you know for a woman going outside in
general 100
um but the the one about going out
without a mahram you know there are some
cases where it's allowed for a woman if
she's just you know going out
um obviously if the husband is not okay
with his wife just going out or the
father is not okay with you know his
daughter just going out randomly you
know there is a level of authority that
he has in a level of respect that he has
to be given in regards to that but it
should not be taken to an extremes or in
any kind of Oppression I think you do
raise a fair point
um even if it doesn't exactly apply to
the going outside because I think
there's a lot greater risk of a woman
being out late than a man being out late
like yeah maybe a man would be robbed
but um I don't think that's anywhere
close to as bad as what might happen to
a woman especially if she's not with a
man I think if she's out with somebody
who's gonna protect her okay I think
that's her but if she's out alone and
just a small group of girls I don't
think that is something that is
preferable especially islamically you
know there's there's a vast evidence for
that but when it comes to things like
you know if you have a sister who
doesn't wear hijab and a man who doesn't
cover like his belly button or is you
know he's always like naked yeah then a
lot of people especially men are willing
to kind of jump at the woman like what's
wrong with you cover yourself have shame
and you know they look at the same guys
you know they'll be like wow you know
look at him doing I don't know look at
him playing basketball even though he's
you know his Aura is showing his knees
and his belly button they're like wow
look at him you know dunk and they're
not even paying attention to that I
think there is a huge point to be made
about things like that so Jacques for
sharing that
thank you of course of course all right
um I think that's it from me do you
sisters have any questions or any points
you want to make before we end in fire
do you have any questions before we end
Ed no questions but I want to know if
the sisters have any questions for us
and then we can wrap it up
three questions thank you no
nope all right all right guys so if you
made it this far comment down below
hashtag no because men and women cannot
be friends so we know who made it till
the end and with that being said
inshallah brother
all right alhamdulillah we've had
consistently 400 viewers through this
whole stream which means we should have
at least 10 000 likes right now may
Allah bless you guys immensely and with
that being said